the situation in greater manchester is
grave and it worsens
with each passing day cases doubled in
the last
nine days high infection rates are
creeping up
the age rate age range while cases
are 690 per 100 000 for 16 to 29 year
olds
they've now risen to 224
per 100 000 for the over 60s
the number of coveted inpatients in
manchester's icu beds
is already over 40 percent of the number
at the height of the first wave that
number
will inevitably rise further given that
hospitalization
occurs two to three weeks after
infection
on present trends in just over two weeks
there will be more
covered patients in intensive care
than at the peak of the first wave
so i urge the mayor to reconsider
and engage constructively i cannot
stress enough
time is of the essence each day that
passes before action
is taken means more people will go to
hospital
more people will end up in intensive
care and
tragically more people will die of
course
if agreement cannot be reached i will
need
to intervene in order to protect
manchester's hospitals and save the
lives of manchester's
residents but our efforts
will be so much more effective if we
work
together some have argued that we should
introduce
a national lockdown instead of targeted
local action and i disagree closing
businesses in cornwall
where transmission is low will not cut
transmission
in manchester so while i can't rule
anything out
if at all possible i want to avoid
another
national lockdown with the damaging
health economic
and social effects it would have